eric woerth sera l'invité du ne faut
jurer de rien bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne l'audition de
philippe séguin le président de la cour
des comptes par la commission des
finances du sénat
cette audition intervient alors que le
déficit budgétaire a augmenté de 47% en
2008 pour s'établir à 56,3 milliards
d'euros ce qui signifie que pour la
première fois la france va dépenser plus
d'argent pour honorer ses dettes que
pour préparer l'avenir de ses enfants
pour philippe séguin il est donc
indispensable de partir à la reconquête
de recettes fiscales selon lui elles ont
beaucoup trop baissé en raison à des
allègements d'impôts
le président de la cour des comptes qui
menace de ne plus certifié les comptes
de l'état si la situation ne changeait
pas bonne matinée à tous nous
accueillons maintenant monsieur philippe
seguin en sa qualité de premier
président de la cour des comptes
je le premier président merci d'avoir
bien voulu venir devant une autre
commission des finances pour nous
présenter les rapports de la cour
relatif à la certification des comptes
de l'état et à l'exécution budgétaire de
2008 pourrait vous demander de bien
vouloir excuser cet accueil tardif
puisque nos aux travaux ont débordé par
rapport à l'horaire monsieur le premier
président vous avez la parole vieux
monsieur président monsieur le
rapporteur général et la mission ici
matters
c'est toujours pour moi un grand honneur
que de venir vous présenter les travaux
de la cour sur les finances publiques
nous vous livrons aujourd'hui de deux
mesures dans l'acte de certification des
comptes de l'état pour l'exercice 2008 à
l'excès comme il se doit au projet de
loi de règlement et le rapport sur les
résultats la gestion budgétaire de
l'état pour l'année 2008 qui a été
conformément aux dispositions de la lolf
déposée conjointement au dépôt par le
gouvernement du projet drogue ces deux
documents seront très bientôt suivi par
le traditionnel rapport sur la situation
et les perspectives des finances
publiques rapport destiné à vous aider à
préparer le débat d'orientation
budgétaire
mais vous êtes habitué à ce rendez vous
je tiens néanmoins souligné les
nouveautés 2009
la première la plus importante est que
nous inscrivons dans un nouveau cadre
constitutionnel et notamment dans le
cadre de l'article 47 de la constitution
qui est venu très opportunément précisé
compléter la définition de notre mission
auprès de vous nous avons vu monsieur le
président vous le savez un signe de
l'excellence d'une relation et je tenais
à vous remercier à nouveau pour le rôle
que vous allez jouer pour conforter au
sommet la hiérarchie des normes la
relation si fondamental des deux
assemblées du parlement et de la cour la
deuxième nouveauté que nous avons pu
réserver cette année nous serons
désormais régulièrement réservé dijon
parlement la primeur de la présentation
complète de nos travaux sur le budget
les comptes de l'état
si nous avons été contraints de rendre
public le lac de certification lundi
dernier puisqu'il devait être annexée au
projet de loi de règlement avant son
examen en conseil d'état
son passage en conseil des ministres
vous êtes les premiers destinataires du
rapport sur le résultat la gestion
budgétaire et les premiers destinataires
cela sans dire des commentaires que nous
souhaitons faire sur l'ensemble de ces
travaux
dernière innovation enfin les notes
d'exécution budgétaire par mission ainsi
que les notes d' analyse par programme
constitue pour la première fois des
annexes du rapport sur les résultats
c'était là une demande forte de votre
commission
il y a été satisfait nous avons modifié
nos procédures vous faire parvenir les
documents les plus lisibles et les plus
utiles le possible ils sont encore
perfectibles
j'espère qu'ils pourront d'ores et déjà
vous aider et aider notamment bien sûr
des rapports spéciaux un permettez moi
enfin de dire combien je partage avec
votre commission le souci de transformer
l'examen du projet de loi de règlement
moment de vérité les initiatives que
vous avez prises l'an dernier pour
auditionner les ministres et faire ce
rendez vous un véritable moment de débat
et de réflexion nous semble tout à fait
essentiel et d'eau travaux n'ont pas
d'autre but que de vous accompagner dans
cette démarche
quelques commentaires maintenant s'ils
voulaient bien sur le fond avant de
revenir successivement sur lac de
certification puis sur le rapport sur
les résultats
je voudrais vous faire part des
remarques de la cour concernant
l'application de la lolf
nous sommes en effet qu'il ya là un
enjeu majeur que la crise que nous
traversons ne doit pas nous conduire à
occulter tout au contraire
vous avez voté cette loi la quasi
unanimité en deux l'un visait une plus
grande transparence des finances de
nectar et de meilleures performances
publiques
force est néanmoins de reconnaître que
trois années après elle implique la plie
de l'entrée en vigueur de l'intégralité
de ces dispositions
les résultats ne sont pas encore au
rendez vous le big bang budgétaire et
comptable n'a pas produit le choc
culturel attendu et je serai tentait de
parler du risque d'un rendez vous manqué
je commence par la réforme comptable ce
n'est pas devant ceux qui sont à
l'origine cette réforme que je vais
refaire la démonstration de l'intérêt
pour l'état de disposer comme les
entreprises une véritable comptabilité
patrimoniale
c'est pas à vous qui avez voté voulu et
voté le nouvel article 2 que je vais
démontrer l'intérêt de disposer de
comptes réguliers sincères et fidèles
des comptes fiable constitue un outil de
gestion primordial est indispensable
pour l'administration
car pour bien gérer il faut connaître et
bien anticipé des comptes fiable
c'est aussi le préalable à une mesure
une analyse des coûts des actions des
politiques publiques
c'est donc un préalable à une véritable
mesure des performances
je dirais volontiers que sans mesures
d'aperçu pas de mesure de performances
sans analyse des coûts pas d' analyse
des coûts sans comptabilité générale des
comptes le fiable c'est aussi la
condition d'une analyse économique
approfondie une analyse de la
soutenabilité des finances publiques en
particulier il faudra bien grand qu'on
tire les enseignements opérationnel de
concepts tels que la situation nette qui
mesure l'écart entre les actifs et les
passifs
ou encore des engagements hors bilan ces
derniers vous le savez sont susceptibles
de se transformer en passif comme les
banques que l'ont appris à leurs dépens
depuis le déclenchement de la crise des
prêts hypothécaires à alès si ces
enseignements ne peuvent pas être
identique à ce que contiendra une
entreprise l'état n'a pas les plus
pessimistes dirait d'un a pas encore à
réfléchir à sa continuité d'exploitation
je suis convaincu qu'ils ont leur
utilité pour les parlementaires mais
d'abord nous aussi pour les analystes
les gestionnaires et plus généralement
les citoyens la nouvelle comptabilité
est aussi un vecteur d'information sans
équivalent pour vous qui vous apprêtez à
débattre du projet de loi de règlement
pour 2008 et des orientations
budgétaires pour 2010 car elle est en
quelque sorte un indicateur avancé des
charges que l'état aura assumé dans les
toutes prochaines années et plus
particulièrement 2010 c'est dire que la
nouvelle comptabilité constitue un
tableau de bord unique pour l'ensemble
des acteurs de la gestion publique
la vraie difficulté c'est que les
acteurs en tout cas la plupart des
acteurs ne se sont pas approprié ces
nouvelles informations
comment il serait il a cité d'ailleurs
alors que le gouvernement se montre lui
même timide en la matière ne faisant par
exemple aucun lien réel entre la réforme
comptable et la révision générale des
politiques publiques
c'est là en tout cas notre principale
préoccupation est cette remarque vaut
tout autant pour la réforme budgétaire
un effort très important a été consenti
pour le classer tout le budget de l'état
vous le savez bien dans des missions des
problèmes
dotée d'objectifs et d'indicateurs la
lolf a également conduit un désigner des
responsables de programme dispose en
principe d'une plus grande liberté
d'utilisation des crédits mais pour user
d'un euphémisme de ces féminisme qui
nous sont chères ces nouveaux outils ne
sont pas utilisés autant qu'ils le
pourraient en d'autres termes dire plus
cléments l'administration mais
elle souvent dans le vide
les responsables de programme ils sont
pourtant au coeur de la nouvelle gestion
budgétaire peine pour la plupart à
s'imposer faute de définition précise de
leur mission et de la prérogative par
rapport notamment aux ordonnateurs on
nous les a présentés chacun s'en
souvient comme des gestionnaires doté de
super pouvoirs qui devait permettre
d'améliorer les performances publiques
or force est de reconnaître que bien
souvent le responsable de programme des
responsables de quasiment rien
concurrence c'est qu'il est par le
directeur du personnel le directeur
financier
le secrétaire général du ministère
auquel il appartient parallèlement la
programmation de gestion et le suivi des
crédits sont encore effectué pour partie
selon des modalités proche de celle qui
prévalait avant la publication de la
noise pris la fongibilité des crédits
qui était censée inciter les
gestionnaires notamment dans les
services déconcentrés à mieux gérer est
encore peu utilisée alors certes des
mesures récentes comme la construction
de perspective budgétaire pluri-annuel
ont permis quelques progrès mais on est
encore très loin du compte
on est très loin du compte en matière de
remontée d'informations en matière de
choix grincer les dents des indicateurs
ou en matière de l'adaptation des moyens
budgétaires en fonction des résultats
les indicateurs notamment n'ont pas
trouvé leur place dans le débat public
en bref sur les cinquante deux missions
rares sont celles où l'on peut relever
de véritables progrès qui soit en lien
avec l'application de la lolf
je pense être bien compris nous
approuvons entièrement la démarche
engagée nous n'avions d'hommes appelée
de nos voeux ce que nous critiquons ce
qui nous préoccupe ce sont les modalités
actuelles d'application de cette réforme
qui mobilise une énergie très importante
sans que ses utilisateurs dans tire les
fruits promis la lolf je le répète à
dessein n'est pas en cause même si
certaines modifications pour toujours
lui être apportées il faut reconnaître
que seule une impulsion politique fort
serait de nature à favoriser sa pleine
utilisation et à venir à bout des
résistances de tout gendre qui j'aime
son application
l'enjeu est de taille parce que comme
vous je pense nous considérons que la
lolf et les de voûte de la réforme de
l'état
j'en viens maintenant plus précisément
sur lac de certification pour probant
dit cette année nous certifions une
nouvelle fois les coûts de l'état avec
12 réserves dont neuf sont importantes
et qualifiées de substantielles en
certifiant les comptes malgré tout la
cour a voulu comme les deux années
passées adopter une démarche
constructive l'idée c'est de ne pas
chercher à clouer au pilori l'état mais
de l'accompagner dans une démarche
indispensable de modernisation et je
suis je reste convaincu que ce
positionnement qui a été adoptée depuis
trois ans et le bon la preuve d'ailleurs
nous avons constaté un certain nombre
d'améliorations de progrès par rapport
aux comptes de 2007
nous avons ainsi cette année levé deux
réserves et ce sont deux succès deux
progrès significatifs qui convient de
saluer d'autant plus que nous ne serons
pas plus sans peine la première de ces
réserves concerné la valeur patrimoniale
du compte des procédures publiques de
soutien à l'exportation
j'irai par la coface qui est estimé à
8,2 milliards de 600 millions et celle
de la section des fonds des pales qui
retenu finalement pour sa valeur à fin
2007 soit 7 milliards 600 millions
d'euros et qui s'ajoutent au coût
d'acquisition de la participation de
l'état dans la caisse des dépôts et
consignations la seconde réserve
intégralement levé a concerné les
provisions pour risques
c'est aussi
l'âne avancées significatives nous
pouvons nous féliciter d'autres progrès
encore d'une part dans la réserve sur
les produits régaliens le désaccord sur
les déficits fiscaux reportables en
avant a été réglé tout comme d'ailleurs
de désaccords sur les immobilisations
incorporelles spécifique au total
l'accord a formulé 283 observations
d'audit et obtenu des corrections les
ajustements significatifs dans les côtes
pour un montant de 9 milliards d'euros
aux coûts de résultats de 27 milliards
au bilan est de 33 milliards en
engagements hors bilan et je voudrais
une permission matin des brûlements sur
certaines avancées 2008 parce qu'elle
illustre bien ce qu'apporte la
comptabilité générale
tout d'abord la diffusion progressive
d'une culture d'une maîtrise des risques
au sein de l'état qui désormais recense
mieux les litiges et les risques divers
auxquels il est exposé et leurs
conséquences financières
cela s'est mieux connaître ensuite la
plus grande transparence de
l'information en annexe si par exemple
chiffre désormais le stock des déficits
fiscaux qui viendront s'imputer sur les
futures recettes d'impôts ce stock
s'établit aujourd'hui à 245 milliards
d'euros il a pas venant réduire les
recettes à venir est estimé à près de 35
milliards d'euros sur l'impôt sur les
revenus et 1 milliard cela pousserait
société pardonnez moi et un milliard sur
l'impôt sur le revenu
cela c'est aussi se donner les moyens le
bleu prévoir enfin il faut noter
l'inscription bilan de l'état de
nouveaux actifs
c'est le cas des licences umts et gsm
pour plus de 4 milliards d'euros ou des
droits d'émission des gaz
effet de serre alloués aux entreprises
pour une lente pour 14 milliards c'est
le cas aussi d'une trentaine
d'opérations d'armement dont la
valorisation a pu être viabilisés je
pense par exemple à l'avion de transport
a400m et l'ensemble de ces éléments doit
selon nous donner à l'état des moyens
pour mieux gérer alors d'importantes
difficultés dans de leur poule il reste
d'avoir des problèmes de périmètre l'un
des plus délicats porte sur la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale
cades est ce la cour considère en effet
que cette entité est contrôlé par l'état
qui en assure mme in fine et les risques
et la responsabilité sont reclassement
en entités contrôlées aboutir et à
grever la situation de l'état de 80
milliards voire davantage au vu des
déficits annoncés des organismes de
sécurité sociale pour 2009 par ailleurs
plusieurs chantiers destinés à lever des
réserves importantes accusent des
retards dont la cour ne peut pas
s'accommoder j'en donnerai deux simples
exemples c'est le cas d'abord du
patrimoine immobilier
ça fait maintenant un bon nombre
d'années qu'on attend que l'état fasse
un inventaire exhaustif et fiable de ses
biens immobiliers
l'objectif n'est toujours pas atteint
j'ai récemment entendu d'importants
responsables glissant le budget d'hier
qu'on pouvait très bien conduire une
politique immobilière efficace sans
disposer d'un inventaire comptable à
jour j'en doute pour ma part simple
exemple ou l'amant vient d'annoncer son
intention d'allouer une surface de 12
mètres carrés par poste de travail
il sera difficile de faire respecter
cette table d'occupation sans un
inventaire exhaustif du parc immobilier
alors le deuxième exemple concerne les
opérateurs les opérateurs c'est à dire
ces entités chargées d'un service public
qui ont la personnalité juridique mais
sont sous le contrôle de l'état
elle figure dans ses comptes pour plus
de 55 milliards d'euros
alors ce que nous observons depuis trois
ans maintenant c'est que le recensement
n'est toujours pas fiable que ces
opérateurs ne produisent pas leur compte
dans les délais impartis hic ces comptes
sont encore souvent de qualité médiocre
dont j'ai par exemple que fin 2008
plusieurs opérateurs comme le centre des
monuments nationaux ou l'opéra de paris
d'inscrits mais pas leur milandes et des
monuments historiques ou l'eau ou des
oeuvres d'art entre les alors même que
c'est bien justifient leur existence
2009 sur un an qu une année critique
nous sommes en effet dans le quatrième
exercice qui sera l'an prochain
soumia certification nous sommes bien
sûr tout à fait disposé à rester
compréhensive sur les sujets que nous
considérons ne pas pouvoir
raisonnablement être résolu à brève
échéance
c'est le cas de la réserve portant sur
les systèmes d'information ceux ci ne
sont pas adaptés aux nouvelles exigences
des nouvelles normes de comptable pour
déployer un système adapté il faut du
temps même si on peut recruter regretter
certains des retards qui se sont
accumulés mais nous avons conscience de
la difficulté du processus
et cet aspect peu à nos yeux justifier
la patience du certificateur nous sommes
beaucoup plus perplexe sur le retard
pris sur d'autres chantiers où les
progrès sont pourtant à portée de main
les comptes de trésorerie
le patrimoine immobilier les produits
régaliens les passifs d'intervention
les inventaires d'actif et de passif des
ministères civils
ici une dîme m
dynamique renouvelée n'est pas impulsé
il faudra bien finir par en tirer les
conséquences
faute de quoi on enlèverait à l'exercice
de certification sa signification et on
risquerait d'affaiblir si on veut
continuer sa crédibilité aux yeux de la
communauté financière
comme l'on dit j'en arrive maintenant
rapport sur les résultats d'ing gestion
budgétaire
ce rapport se nourrit de trois approches
une approche traditionnelle de contrôle
de l'exécution budgétaire une approche
plus nouvelle d'un analyse croisée des
résultats en comptabilité budgétaire et
entre tabilité patrimoniale résultats
qui s'éclaire et se complètent ce qui
permet d'avoir une vision plus précise
de la situation et enfin une troisième
approche centrée sur l'analyse des
nouveaux dispositifs lolf que j'ai déjà
évoqué au début de mon propos ce rapport
sur les résultats vous est présentée au
terme des premiers mois de l'exercice
2009 dont on sait déjà qu'il va se
caractériser par un déficit et un
endettement comme l'état dans n'a jamais
connu en tout plat dans notre histoire
moderne et en temps de paix alors 2008
il faut savoir se dégage mois achevée
c'est déjà achevés
j'ai une très forte dégradation du
déficit alors comme vous le savez selon
le projet de loi de règlement le déficit
du budget de l'état s'établit à 56
milliards 300 millions d'euros en
augmentation de près de 47% par rapport
à 2007
non pour se faire une idée il faut
peut-être quitter un instant les
pourcentages auquel nous sommes habitués
pourcentage maastricht 3% de déficit 3
et demi pour cent même quatre mêmes
quatre et demi le mi5 sait-on jamais bon
ça peut préoccuper m'enfin ça ça ne me
donne pas en tout cas l'opinion la
mesure de la réalité des situations la
réalité de la situation peut-être que
nos vidéos il sera plus sensible si on
compare le déficit total des recettes de
l'état
56 milliards ça représente un quart des
recettes annuelles de l'état c'est à
dire qu'elle est sur des deux côtés et
il manque un car un quart de la somme ça
ça peut parler alors le travail de la
cour a été d'analyser ce résultat vous
en montrer des tenants et les
aboutissants ici est un message que nous
souhaitons faire passer
conséquence 2008 c'est bien que la crise
n'a eu un impact que limitée qu encore
l'image et
en d'autres termes et j'insiste sur ce
point
la dégradation du déficit n'est pas un
sip allemand due à la crise c'est dire
que les conclusions de ce rapport
doivent être plus avec attention car
elle révèle des tendances de fond que la
conjoncture ne doit pas conduire à
ignorer ou à négliger
avant cela je dois quelques éclairages
complémentaires sur résultats affichés
dans projet de loi de règlement
comme les années précédentes ce résultat
ne prend pas en compte un certain nombre
de dépenses plus de dette pourtant il y
eut pourtant exigible ne prend pas en
compte par exemple 5 milliards 900
millions d'euros tirés du juridiquement
être payante 2008 mais qui ne l'ont pas
été il s'agit de les 3 milliards 6 dû à
la sécurité sociale et 2,1 milliards
neuf cent cinquante millions au titre
des programmes d'armement ce résultat
prend pas en compte les 953 millions de
dépenses des prix le dépanne logement
payé en dehors du budget de l'état au
moyen d'avancés rémunéré du prédit
sommes sentis par le crédit foncier
au total ces dettes exigibles ces
dépenses représentent 5 milliards
d'euros vous l'aurez observé nous nous
abstenons nous prononcer sur la
sincérité du résultat affichait le
projet de règlement eu égard à la
jurisprudence actuelle du conseil
constitionnel que sur les ti jusqu'à
présent de s'en tenir à un examen de
l'exactitude des comptes alors un
élément de nouveau et néanmoins
intervenu le dernier alinéa du nouvel
article 47 d'un état qui est bien connu
de cette commission qui dispose que les
comptes des administrations publiques
sont réguliers et sincères qu'ils
donnent une image fidèle du résultat de
leur gestion
de leur patrimoine et de lust caution
financière
alors cette nouvelle disposition
s'applique-t-elle seulement à la
comptabilité patrimoniale comme vous le
prétendez déjà certains concerne-t-elle
également les résultats budgétaires
comme d'autres me lisent
si oui dans quelles conditions c'est pas
un autre est pour moi la question mais
elle se pose assurément nous ne
reprenons donc à notre compte
aucun chiffre alternatif de déficit nous
sommes contentés cette année de vous
donner les informations nécessaires pour
mieux comprendre ce que recours et
chante ou d'ailleurs ce que ne recouvre
pas le résultat affiché force est
d'ailleurs de reconnaître que si
l'analyse détaillée d'exécution
budgétaire révèle un certain nombre
d'eux des rames en on sens originel du
terme d'habitude bien connu de la cour
comme la somme budgétisation les reports
de charges les compensations entre
recettes et dépenses
ces pratiques ne paraissent pas avoir
été plus importante cette année que les
années précédentes
non la véritable difficulté cette année
j'y reviens née du caractère structurel
et pas seulement conjoncturel de la
dégradation du résultat
sous l'effet de deux tendances de fond
une diminution des recettes nettes
recettes fiscales et non fiscales qui
est imputable que très partiellement
avec reese une croissance encore
insuffisamment maîtrisée des dépenses
qui ne doit encore rien à l'effet des
mesures prises dans le cadre du plan de
relance et j'aurais revenir
successivement sur ces deux éléments les
recettes cette année sont à la fois les
recettes fiscales et les recettes non
fiscales
c'est à dire celles liées aux cessions
d'actifs immobiliers ou une
participation dans les entreprises
ce sont donc ses recettes là qui ont
diminué les recettes fiscales nettes
diminuent pour la troisième année
consécutive
elles ont baissé de 2 et demi pour cent
par rapport à 2007
tendance qui s'explique principalement
par deux facteurs le premier le
transfert de recettes derlot de
l'administration pour 6 milliards cent
dont 1,3 pour les collectivités
territoriales
4 3 pour les organismes de sécurité
sociale
quand serait aux collectivités
territoriales sont d'abord liées aux
transferts de compétences qui allège
d'autant les dépenses de l'état en
revanche les transferts opérés ou 2008
fera sécurité sociale vise à compenser l
des moins-values de recettes résultant
de décision d'exonération de cotisations
sociales prises par l'état s'agit donc
d'un coup sans contrepartie pour les
dons de second facteurs d'érosion des
recettes fiscales elie aux allègements
d'impôts tu écoutais 7 milliard 800
millions en 2008
les seules dispositions fiscales de la
loi tepa distincte des dispositions en
matière de cotisations sociales que j'ai
développés ont notamment coûté 3
milliards 200 millions d'euros
alors la crise a certes aggravé la
situation bino estimant que son impact
sur les recettes est inférieur à 4
milliards d'euros
comment avons nous à ce chiffre le
raisonnement est assez simple tout
d'abord les prévisions de croissance
pour 2008 faite par le gouvernement le
conduisent à anticiper des recettes de
l'ordre de 200 que points 3 milliards
soit une augmentation de 16 et 17
milliards sur l'année précédente
or les recettes de 2008 ont été de 260
milliards en retrait de 7,6 milliards
par rapport à 2007 et surtout de 23
millions
par rapport à la prévision de la loi de
finances initiale c'était car à
plusieurs explications des
surestimations dans la prévision pour
sablière les faits en 2008 de nouveaux
allègements d'impôts pour 7,8 je voulais
dit d'être ancienne recette voulait
évoquer aucun culte entre la ds pour 6
milliards cent il reste donc à delta
dont d'expliquer de 4 milliards d'euros
dont on peut penser qu'il est
l'incidence de la crise pour tout ou
partie
donc l'impact de la crise est
relativement faible au regard des autres
facteurs d'érosion de l'equilibre leur
parallèlement il est vrai les dépenses
ont continué à croître l'ensemble des
dépenses et augmenter en valeur de 2,8
si on se réfère à la norme de
progression figurant dans la loi de
finances initiale qui ne correspond qu'à
une partie de ses dépenses
d'accroissement des dépenses on est dû
est de 0,3 en volume et de 1,9 en valeur
l'augmentation en valeur étaient
supérieurs par le hasard des chiffres
cette alimentation s'étaient même filer
aussi à 2008
mais ceci n'est que la conséquence une
inflation plus importante que prévu
toutefois il résulte des anis la coke et
dépenses des dépenses ont été
régulièrement pays en deux ans le budget
de l'état il s'agit d'une part d'une
partie des primes départ du logement qui
ont été payants moyens avance rémunéré
du crédit foncier de france je vous en
ai parlé l'autre part d'une partie des
sommes dues à la sécurité sociale qui a
fait l'objet d'une compensation recettes
et dépenses pour 753 millions
et si on intègre c'est simple qui aurait
dû donner due à des dépenses budgétaires
dans les dépenses relevant de la donne
l'augmentation des dépenses pourrait
être de 3%
elle a par ailleurs que vous le savez
cette norme ne couvre pas toutes les
dépenses notamment celles titre ainsi
page contribution ou en opérations
trésorerie si le périmètre de la dame a
bien été élargie en 2008 dans le sens
préconisé par la cour des progrès
restent encore à faire enfin surtout
j'allais jeudi recettes ne couvrent pas
les dépenses fiscales qui de leur côté
ont augmenté de 7% par rapport à 2007 et
qui représente 1 dans plus de 73
milliards d'euros alors en la matière
nous avons dont nous avons je reviens
volets soit dépensé nous avons certes
constaté un certain nombre d'avancées
que nous savions de notre rapport une
amélioration de l'information donnée
dans les projets des rapports annuels de
performance
la création de l'objectif annuel de
dépenses fiscales ou l'obligation de
galles j'ai toute nouvelle dépense
fiscale
mais le chemin à faire pour une
meilleure maîtrise meilleure évaluation
de ces dépenses restent reste long
alors en médecins de dépenses convient
également de préciser comme je viens de
le faire pour les recettes que l'impact
de la crise est restée limitée pour 2008
le plan de relance pèsera surtout sur
2009 quant au plan de soutien des
banques il a essentiellement consisté en
la mise en place de dispositifs de
garantie n'a pas induit de déboursement
de la part de l'état hormis en me l'a
prise de participation dans le cadre du
sauvetage du groupe dexia pour un
milliard d'euros
mais prise de participation qui a
elle-même été partiellement remboursée
avant la fin de l'année
de la même façon le plan de financement
dès que d'oubli n'a pas eu non plus
d'effets enfin des faits sur les
chiffres que je vous rapporte en 2008
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
la comptabilité patrimoniale permet de
préciser le diagnostic et contribue
malheureusement l'europe encore plus
sombre l'évolution du bilan fait
notamment apparaître un net
alourdissement de la dette notamment de
la dette financière fin 2008
elle dépasse pour la première fois les
100 milliards d'euros les bills milliard
locales et jubile milliard d'euros ce
sont près de 100 milliards
supplémentaires voilà la récente d'un
demande est rare ce sont 100 milliards
supplémentaires par rapport aux
précédentes c'est quand même de notation
depuis de 10% des situations nettes
c'est à dire la différence entre les
actifs les passifs ce n'est la ville
également même s'il faut interpréter
cette évolution est dense ce stade
puisque par définition tous les actifs
ne sont pas qu'on ressent c'est là le
résultat comptable révèle également une
importante dégradation moins 131 % en
deux ans le solde net des opérations
d'exercice s'établit cette année à moins
73 milliards d'euros alors d'où vient ce
résultat est très bien en premier la
progression des charges de l'état toutes
les charges sont concernés les charges
d'intervention qui ont progressé de 20 %
les charges financières qui ont augmenté
de 16 2% et les charges de
fonctionnement ont progressé de 6,1 pour
cent et nous avons encore un indicateur
avancé des dépenses à venir
changer ce que serait la comptabilité
des entreprises si elles ne raisonnait
que sur la base des budgets de leurs
divisions ou de leurs filiales
la force de la comptabilité générale et
de relier des actifs à des produits des
passifs à décharge et de surveiller de
près les engagements or bien car votre
commission demande aux costumes
provisions budgétaires sur les
obligations indexées le producteur des
comptes passe une écriture nous incombe
de bilan quand la lolf exige que ce
qu'on a suivi les charges ressources de
trésorerie
ce sont des contes de comptabilité
générale qui sont touchés d'où la
question que nous posons pourquoi mais
pas sauter le pas pourquoi ne pas
raisonner sur la base des grands
agrégats de comptabilité générale
pourquoi ne pas faire de l'index le
vecteur de l'analyse de la soutenabilité
budgétaire comme le font par exemple les
états unis depuis bien des années
celui d'un secteur privé l'index
constitue une partie tout à fait central
des états financiers que les
commissaires aux comptes scrutin
d'autant plus d'attention fait de la
crise nous avons fait le même effet un
ex comporte des informations
essentielles c'est notamment le cas de
saint-yvi club l'ensemble des
conséquences financières de la dite
crise pendant l'examen des garanties
octroyées aux établissements de crédit
dexia et sa filiale américaine avait
fait ça en particulier la cour a insisté
pour que l'index ne se contente pas de
mentionner les 22 milliards d'euros de
garanties effectivement débloqués mais
détaille aussi le plafond autorisé par
la loi de finances soit près de 60
milliards d'euros
et cet exemple illustre l'apport de
nouvelles comptabilité est labellisé
engagements de l'état
je pourrais citer aussi les engagements
de retraite sur lesquels l'information
et qui enrichit la suite d'adn audit
approfondi bhl
pour vous y trouverez à la fois les
engagements bolt correspondent à tous
les droits active au 31 décembre 2008
par tous les fonctionnaires en activité
retraités ou leurs ayants cause c'était
bien bill 57 milliards d'euros
mais aussi le besoin de financement
actualisées pour la fonction publique
d'état
pour les régimes sociaux subventionnés
et pour les ouvriers d'état soit un
total de 5 149 milliards d'euros à
l'horizon 2050 la comptabilité générale
permet ainsi de mieux cerner l'ensemble
des risques et des engagements de l'état
bien au delà des apparences parfois trop
plat il faut bien l'avenir de la
comptabilité budgétaire
alors mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
j'avais au terme de broc propos
introductif quelles conclusions tirées
de l'ensemble de ces constats quel peut
être le rôle de la cour dans ce contexte
je pense qu'il est de contribuer une
certaine lucidité n'est pas eu d'abord
de s'enfermer dans la déploration mais
de bien content que les finances de
l'état ne sont pas simplement crise
continue et pull jamais de souffrir
d'une maladie chronique
il est probablement nécessaire
d'attaquer le problème à sa racine est à
cet égard la cour voudrait que soit
entendue trois ses messages le premier
porte sur le décès cité de lutter contre
le déficit structurel l'état à bord de
la crise avec un déficit structurel de 3
5%
pour nous ce qui ne lui laisse aucune
marque de même il faut donc reconstituer
ses marges
et pour cela il semble la cour qu'il
faudrait deux dès qu'un coup d'arrêt à
la baisse des recettes
côté dépenses la norme croissance zéro
en volume ne sera évidemment pas
suffisante pour relever le défi faut
engager des réformes structurelles bien
plus importante et probablement
douloureuses que celles qui sont en
cours il faudra peut-être faire des
choix parmi les politiques publiques ou
à tout le moins sur leur ford ce que le
rapport ces résultats dit à propos de
l'état le rapport sur la situation et
les perspectives des finances publiques
le dire à l'échelle de l'ensemble
ministration public mais il est
important nous semble-t-il de mettre en
évidence la part de l'effort qui revient
à l'état pour éviter de serre porter une
responsabilité qui pourrait paraître
inutilement exclusive sur la sécurité
sociale et sur les collectivités
territoriales
le deuxième message concerne la lolf ou
bien au kanak à la porte de véritables
progrès on peut même dire que les
mauvaises pratiques actuelles sont des
perpétuation dans un système tandis que
les bugs sont souvent un premier acquis
de la nouvelle gestion publique
mais cet acquis est fragile et il est
insuffisant et dont convient donc de le
consolider l'amplifier et de façon
urgente la crise dont seulement doit pas
être un prétexte relâchement de l'effort
bien l'appel fasse pas mener fort
fréquenté de parodier malraux qui disait
qu'on ne va pas au bord du rubis ton
pour les pêcheurs à la ligne
on ne sait pas une réforme de cette
ampleur pour ne pas l'appliquer en tirer
les fruits et alors que la france
traverse une et plus grave récession de
son histoire il serait primordial que
les acteurs s'approprient les nouveaux
outils à leur disposition
qui sont des outils qui peuvent être
doivent être efficace il faudrait donc
un un changement de braquet dans la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme budgétaire et
comptable engagée si nous voulons
préserver la crédibilité des signatures
de france le plus tôt sera le mieux
l'enjeu c'est la tension constante quand
une pétition à ces problématiques
je sais et fort qu'il vaut pour faire
des contrôles inventaire a lieu décisif
de réforme de l'état ce gène ou
partageant vos occupations ne ménagerons
pas nos efforts pour vous assister dans
cette démarche
je vous remercie de votre attention je
président le soin porté en général les
messieurs les sénateurs et je me tiens à
votre disposition
allez messieurs les juges au président
de la première chambre de la cour et de
la formation interne quand je suis à
cheval tosa je le faisais m bih ce
monsieur bouton servant d'elle selon des
moniteurs pour répondre aux questions
que vous pourriez nous poser merci
monsieur le premier président à mettray
deux salves l exercice auquel vous vous
livrez depuis plusieurs années de rendre
hommage à la cour pour ses dirigeants ce
elle à l'apprenti pied duquel manifeste
pour formuler ses conclusions qu'il
s'agisse de la certification des
commentaires sur l'exécution budgétaire
nous avons bien entendu vos messages
monsieur le premier président n'est pas
douteux que la lolf qu'une contribution
à la lucidité politique mais la lolf
sans volonté politique
ça ne sert pas à grand chose donc sans
tout y est ils s'en doutaient soulac il
ya les marges de manoeuvre les plus
importantes des marges de progression
mais sur la situation financière
partageant bien sûr la gravité de votre
appréciation
et j'ai été frappée l'an passé par l'un
de vos commentaires vous vous interrogez
sur l'auditabilité des comptes de l'état
et puis je tire et de vos propos
l'enseignement que cet audit habilité
elles n'auraient pas accompli de progrès
décisifs
c'est bien cela sans doute faudra-t-il
attendre la mise en oeuvre de corus et
car actuellement les services ram pour
essayer de présenter des comptes qui
ressemble à ce qui était prévu par la
lolf
mais avec des instruments qui sont
restés assez rudimentaire et demande
parfois si certains comptables publics
ne vont pas céder au découragement
tan tan tan et c'est en cela que
l'appropriation des nouveaux instruments
est difficile parce que on est resté
avec des systèmes qui n'ont pas changé
et c'est bien là qu'est la difficulté
majeure à mon avis car je ne doute pas
cela sens de la volonté politique et son
des instruments qui nous font défaut
voilà en tout cas merci infiniment
monsieur le président je vais président
de la première chambre vous monsieur
et si vous le voulez bien vous disposez
d'une petite demi heure peut-être pour
une séquence je suis à la disposition
plein et entier
sans limitation non je pense que le
rapporteur général et les questions oui
monsieur le président je vais
autolimitée ces questions et pour
sauvegarder le pluralisme de
l'expression dans notre commission mais
je voudrais appeler l'attention sur deux
séries de choses à bord les éléments
patrimoniaux à la lumière de la crise et
ensuite le sol de courant sur le premier
aspect et nous voyons nos ordres de
grandeurs habituel totalement perturbé
et je relevais dans vos propos monsieur
le premier président au début de votre
propos une phrase dans laquelle vous
disiez la prise en considération dans la
dette de telle opération conduirait à
aggraver le ratio de dette
je ne souhaite pas évoquer l'opération
particulière mais simplement les
considérations de méthode
est ce que c'est la comptabilité
maastrichtienne qui est importante est
ce que c'est la réalité économique
j'ai abordé cette question lundi avec
nos amis britanniques j'étais lundi à
londres pour une série de réunions
notamment sur ces sujets et pour essayer
de comprendre aujourd'hui quel est le
solde des finances publiques
britanniques de source officielle il
faut croiser toute une série de données
et les choses sont extrêmement
indistincte on peut noter que ce pays
que l'on présentait comme très vertueux
qui dégage un solde positif au début des
années 2000 supérieure à 2%
aujourd'hui selon les chiffres officiels
seraient après
2 - 13 % du produit intérieur brut et
que les autorités britanniques ayant été
amenés à secourir le secteur bancaire
par des mesures tout à fait
exceptionnelle et d'un ordre de grandeur
prodigieux par rapport aux agrégats
macroéconomiques ont même été jusqu'à
chiffres et budgétairement parlant une
provision par référence aux risques
couverts par l'état et le taux de cette
provision son mode de calcul
nécessiterait beaucoup de développement
et serait assurément assez contestable
mais en fonction de cet élément de
référence
je voudrais vous demander monsieur le
premier président comment la cour peut
opérer pour apprécier le bon périmètre
car nous avons voté des garanties à des
organismes qui vont emprunter sur le
marché
ces organismes sont des organismes
étatiques n'existe que par l'existence
de l'état et n'emprunteraient pas s'il
n'y avait pas l'état alors qu'est-ce qui
doit entrer dans la dette publique
qu'est ce qui ne doit pas entrer dans la
dette publique et par ailleurs
s'agissant des engagements donnés et
comment donner au parlement et à
l'opinion et dans le cadre européen
la juste notion du hors bilan je vous
avez vous même dans votre propos insisté
sur ces problèmes de méthode et c'est
évidemment un défi considérable car il
faut innover et j'ai compris que vous
nous proposez de donner plus
d'importance aux approches de
comptabilité générale
à l' annexe et peut-être de desserrer le
carcan administratif ou strictement
budgétaires la question précise que j'ai
à vous poser à ce sujet c'est dans cette
approche
etes-vous en contact avec vos homologues
les réviseur des comptes des autres
grands états européens
comment peut-on imaginer monsieur le
premier président que dans cette crise
et encore davantage au moment de la
sortie de crise chacun comptabilise dans
son coin et imagine sa stratégie de
prélèvements obligatoires éventuellement
de manière non coopérative avec son
voisin en sachant que tous devront en
même temps payer la dette qui coûtera
plus cher et relever les prélèvements
obligatoires
pas les uns ou les autres tous donc est
ce que ceci n'appelle pas de la part de
la cour de par sa position de neutralité
et de technicité et une démarche qui
nous permet d'innover parce que
véritablement nous perdons nos repères
et enfin beaucoup plus brièvement sur le
sol de courant j'ai noté dans la
synthèse résultats et gestion budgétaire
des tas exercice 2008
page 9 que la cour chiffre à 3,4 pour
cent
l'augmentation des dépenses du budget
général
alors ceci est bien au delà et de la
norme de la norme élargie qui est de 2,8
et le ministre du budget pour sa part
nous a indiqué qu'il avait quelques
problèmes de compréhension et que
certains mouvements auraient été
comptabilisés deux fois par la cour
dépenses particulièrement dynamiques
comme les pensions ou les charges de la
dette
le compte des pensions le compte de
gestion de la dette trésorerie de l'état
étant alimentée par des versements du
budget
ce prêt président est ce que vous pouvez
et sur cette question du solde courant
et de la bonne tenue de la norme de
dépense et nous nous nous faire partager
la proche de la cour et nous dire
comment le dialogue avec le gouvernement
sur la réalité des chiffres est en train
de se poursuivre voilà
le président je vais m'efforcer de
commencer à répondre à monsieur
rapporteur général
alors s'agissant du dernier problème qui
a évoqué problème un problème important
en ces termes le problème de
compréhension du mystère du budget je
laisserai le soin monsieur babusiaux
d'aller dans le détail
j'observerai simplement que c'est ces
chiffres ont fait l'objet de
contradictions que ministère du budget
qui n'ont jamais appelé de sa part moi
jusqu'à leurs publications la moindre la
moindre réaction et je crois que avoir
omis de réagir et serait d'autant plus
coupable si ces appréciations des dires
étaient confirmés ils étaient excités de
reprise mais j'en viens pour ma part aux
autres problèmes que vous avez évoqué
kita
quitte à paraître étonné soyons pum
connaît dans une vie antérieure
je voudrais quand même prendre la
défense au moins en partie des chiffres
basse très chiant en maintenant un
exemple d'exemple qu'il nous a
beaucoup plus occupé cette année là cad
s je dois reconnaître que la cades s est
déjà dans la dette des administrations
publiques au sens critères de maastricht
au sens enfin des chiffres tels que
définis maastricht et que nous étions
hors en masse très gentille n'étions en
contradiction pardon absolument donc
leur l'alternative retient tant la
réalité économique ou la proche mastri
ciel doit être complétée il y a aussi
une façon de faire qui négligent la
réalité économique tout en négligeant
aussi la passerelle là sur la sur le
royaume uni j'ai pris bonne note de de
ce que vous nous avez rapporté suite en
contact très récente que vous avez vu
sur le déficit il est vrai que les
chiffres les écarts de chiffres entre ce
qui était l légué est ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui sont absolument
considérables sont sereines
le royaume uni serait t'il une nouvelle
elle met de l'est toutes choses égales
par ailleurs
on redécouvre des grappes coup mais je
comprends la réserve que manifester
ministre fourcade car il ya quand même
une grande différence c'est sa
différence elle tient une tête beau en
plus faible que la dette que la dette
française
ça manque certes en face à des bardes
beaucoup plus bas à l'an dernier
dernier point oui nous avons nous avons
contact avec avec les autres viseur cela
étant ce que vous avez dit sur le
paiement de la dette et surtout
l'augmentation des primes obligatoires
nous ramène à à deux questions que
j'évoquerai très brièvement avant de
passer la parole à monsieur muzio la
première
c'est la nécessité qu'il y aurait d'un
mouvement concerté des pays du maximum
de pays de l'union européenne
quant aux décisions qui prendrait en
matière prélèvements obligatoires alors
essayons de faire que d'amal sorte un
bien que ce soit le début de l'ex keith
d'une harmonisation entre les uns et les
autres
et deuxièmement l'autre question qu'on
peut se poser c'est le discours qui
prévaut sur le refus de toute
perspective d'augmentation des
prélèvements qui n'est probablement pas
très mobilisatrice avec la mission de ce
président pij de monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur général
je crois que le la question de
compréhension que vous avez évoqué de la
part du ministre du budget a été tout à
fait temporaire
en fait ce problème de compréhension est
venue du fait que le chiffre de 3,4
correspond fortuitement pour 2008 à deux
réalités différentes
le premier 3,4 c'est l'évolution des
dépenses brutes de l'état entre 2007 et
2008 et le ministre du budget a crû dans
un premier temps que la cour se référer
à ce 3 4 là d'où le fait que le ministre
a fait observer que les dépenses brutes
mérite d'être interprétées avec
précaution puisqu'il faut en déduire non
seulement les dégrèvements et qui paiera
bien sûr pour passer aux dépenses nettes
mais aussi tenir compte d'un certain
nombre de doubles comptes entre le
budget général
les comptes d'affectation spéciale et
les budgets annexes mais ce qui est visé
dans ce que nous analysons ce n'est pas
ce 3,4 là c'est à dire les dépenses
brutes c'est un 3 4
de progression dans le champ de la norme
de dépense et quelle est notre calcul à
cet égard nous est d'ailleurs le
ministre s'est aperçu un de là que
justement il avait en quelque sorte
qu'on fait c'était il avait par mégarde
considéré que c'était le premier 3,4
alors que le chiffre que nous examinons
et que nous produisons c'est le second 3
4 c'est-à-dire le champ de la norme
alors comment arrivons nous as eu 3-4
nous partons de la base des dépenses
effectives dans le champ de la norme de
2007 qui est de 270,6 milliards
c'est le chiffre officiel du
gouvernement c'est lui qui l'a dit 270,6
à ceux de 270,6 le gouvernement a piqué
1,9 pour cent de progression c'était ça
son sa limite c'est-à-dire 5.5 milliards
or le gouvernement reconnaît lui même
que l'augmentation des dépenses dans nos
champs dans le champ de la norme n'a pas
été de 5,5 mais de 7,5 milliards
c'est à dire que selon ses propres
déclarations
l'augmentation est de 2,8 et non pas de
1,9 dans le champ de la nar alors pour
notre part nous considérons que à ses
dépenses à il faute a ajouté ce qui
apparaissait dans l'exposé de tout à
l'heure du vrai président c'est à dire
deux opérations qui aura en réalité
auraient dû être prises en charge en
tant que dépenses
la première c'est une opération de
contraction des dépenses et des recettes
c'est-à-dire que sur la taxe sur les
véhicules à moteur qui avait été
affectée pour partie à la sécurité
sociale en compensation d'exonérations
comme vous vous en souvenez comme cette
taxe a dégagé un surplus de recettes de
753 millions d'euros par rapport à ce
qui devait compenser les exonérations
l'état au lieu d'encaisser cette recette
a considéré qu'elle servait hors du
budget à apurer une partie de la dette
de l'état vis-à-vis de la sécurité
sociale donc au lieu de comptabiliser
d'abord la recette et ensuite de faire
la dépense pour rembourser sa dette
il a fait une opération de contraction
des dépenses et des recettes que prohibe
le droit budgétaire
donc voilà la première opération
contraction donc des dépenses qui ne
sont pas apparus dans le bios deuxième
opération ce sont les primes d'épargné
logement qui ont été supportés par le
crédit foncier de france à hauteur de
953 millions d'euros alors certes le
ministre du budget dit mais ça c'est le
stock de créances et là là le club
l'as vence du crédit foncier est passé
seulement de 350 millions en 2007 650 en
2008 et 950 en 2007 perdant et 950 en
2008 et donc il dit en réalité il n'ya
eu que une aggravation de la vence
crédit foncier de l'ordre de 350
millions d'euros
en réalité ce raisonnement ne nous
paraît pas pouvoir être admis pourquoi
premièrement le ministre du budget est
bien parti pour le calcul de la norme de
la base de 270,6 milliards
donc nous nous nous bornons à regarder
qu'elle a été l'augmentation quel a été
le volume réel des dépenses par rapport
à cette base de 278,6 et puis
incontestablement dès lors que la
dépense était exigible 1
elle devait naturellement être payés et
donc si l'on ajoute 753 millions et 953
millions donc un peu plus d'un milliard
sept et bien on voit que dans la réalité
les dépenses dans le champ de la norme
ont bien progressé de 3 4% et c'est ce 3
4% qui est clairement analysé dans notre
rapport et nous pensons que à côté des
problèmes de recettes il ya bien un
problème de dépenses de la part de
l'état et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs comme
on l'indiquait tout à l'heure lorsque
l'on regarde non plus les le budget de
l'état mais la comptabilité générale on
constate que les charges de l'état ont
augmenté rapidement et plus rapidement
que les dépenses budgétaires a légué
pourquoi et bien c'est justement
notamment parce que il y avait eu des
dépenses hors budget reporter en réalité
à 2009 avant de donner la parole à
madame grès que vais revenir à la
censure ce
justement crédit foncier parce que
aviez-vous fait la même observation à la
fin de l'année 2007
et vous étiez à 6 ans et quelques
millions n'ont donc l'aggravation la
dérive c'est c'est quand même plutôt
logiquement l'adepte de 600 millions
auraient dû apparaître au 1er janvier
mais elle n'est pas apparue non le mit
le gouvernement passe car c'est ça la
magie mais le président sait que si on
suivait le raisonnement terre gros stock
ça n'apparaîtrait jamais au n'ont jamais
ça apparaît ça ne vont pas être
escamotée de la base pourquoi ne faisons
pas tous ensemble et fort un jour donné
d'arrêter de nous raconter des histoires
de cesser de prendre nos les analystes
nos concitoyens partenaires étrangers
pour ce qu'ils ne sont pas je crois
qu'on aurait un intérêt si on veut faire
une vraie pédagogie à a cessé de 2,2 de
trouver des astuces qui font que chacun
doute de la sincérité des comptes
publics
nicole bricq merci monsieur le président
messieurs les présidents je voudrais
vous poser trois questions et la
première a trait aux recettes donc
nous avons bien entendu et lu du reste
la perte de recettes de plus de 7
milliards d'euros pour lors de cette
exécution pour 2008 dont vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le premier président la
crise n'est responsable que dans un
impact limité que vous avez chiffré à
quatre milliards mais moi je voudrais
vous interroger sur la recommandation
que vous faites à l'état concernant les
recettes et notamment quand vous écrivez
que il conviendrait de fonder la
préparation de la loi de finances sur
des hypothèses réalistes et prudente
alors je fais un commentaire c'était
vrai pour 2008 ce sera encore plus vrai
pour 2009
et c'est vrai que la méthode choisie
hantée de bâtir le budget sur une
hypothèse macroéconomique on sait dès le
départ incertaine pour ne pas nuire très
aléatoire conduit le gouvernement à
actualiser au fil de l'eau c'est cette
hypothèse macroéconomique sat est
particulièrement vrai cette année mais
nous avons souvent débattu de cette
question en séance en prenant appui sur
un certain nombre d'exemples étrangers
qui ne choisissent pas cette méthode
qu'elle serait la bonne méthode qui
conduirait à avoir cette hypothèse
prudente et réaliste que vous appelez de
vos voeux
la deuxième observation vous constaté
qu'une part croissante des interventions
publiques passe par les opérateurs de
l'état et vous prenez un exemple assez
significatif qui est le plan de
financement de l'économie ou trois
structures extérieures aux
administrations sont intervenus la spp
eux la fff et la cdp alors vous dites
que ça rend effectivement plus difficile
la lecture
l'exécution le suivi de l'exécution
budgétaire mais vous ne formuler pas de
recommandations et dans votre conclusion
ça a attiré mon attention vous dites que
l'état a recours à ces opérateurs
extérieurs soit pour rechercher une
meilleure efficacité mais souvent pour
de simples raisons d'affichage alors en
l'occurrence je voudrais comprendre
quelles étaient les raisons de du
recours pour cette opération de
financement de l'économie française et
notamment de l'aide apportée soit en
garantie soit en fonds propres aux
banques
et bien qu'elle quelles étaient les
raisons profondes qui ont effectivement
mobilisé trois opérateurs de l'état
rendant votre lecture de l'exécution
délicate et la troisième je l'aurais pas
posée mais il se trouve que avant même
que vous arriviez nous avons examiné un
amendement du gouvernement sur un
véhicule opportun pour lui qui
consistait à rendre droit à l'engagement
de la france lors du dernier conseil
européen et a apporté une contribution
financière au fmi
la contribution de la france de 11
milliards d'euros et je le vois dans
dans vos réserves que concernant les
immobilisations financières de l'état
notamment le traitement comptable des
versements aux organismes internationaux
et notamment au fmi
vous souhaitez pouvoir reconstituer les
versements et
l'administration s'y est engagé avant la
fin de l'année 2009
donc je voudrais comprendre l'intérêt de
cet exercice passée et future est
pourquoi l'administration finalement ne
ne fait pas cette ce traitement
comptable conforme à vos voeux parce que
ça ça a trait à des sommes importantes
même si elles sont justifiées par
ailleurs
ebr évidente jose merci madame le
sénateur ces questions alors fonder la
loi de finances sur des hypothèses
fiable qu'il est la bonne méthode
mais j'aimerais que bien voulu elle même
rappeler que certaines solutions
étrangères était apparemment plus
satisfaisante que la solution française
à laquelle nous sommes accoutumés et qui
consiste si je comprends bien prendre en
considération le sait que les
économistes généralement par prudence
détermine fourchette pour leurs
prévisions de croissance économique et
les rares qu des ministres choisissent
pointe basse de la fourchette
alors bon il existe des méthodes nous ne
sommes pas habilités à suggérer aux
législateurs en la manière en la matière
la façon de me fasse ont procédé ce que
nous sommes autorisés à faire c'est
constater après mais année après année
le décalage qu'il y a il faut espérer il
faut espérer que non mais il peut il
peut exister des formules
constitutionnel ou organiques à mettre
en oeuvre mais là nous sommes sur le
terrain politique mais je ne puis
évidemment exprimé quelques pignons que
ce soit quelques suggestions que ce soit
sauf à redire
madame qu'une observation faite sur ce
décalage est une observation fondé et
vérifier avec une très grande régularité
sur le deuxième point les des opérateurs
de l'état ne considérait surtout pas ma
réponse comme relevant de l'échappatoire
le problème des opérateurs est
effectivement à un problème en général
extrêmement important
ça représente
au minimum deux cent quarante mille
emplois peut-être même 400 milles
si on prend en compte les gens qui
travaillent pour les opérateurs et qui
sont payés par l'état
ça représente les sommes que vous avez
vous même je crois rappelé et cela pose
toute une série toute une série de
problèmes
ne serait ce d'ailleurs que parce que la
liste des opérateurs des plaintes des
opérateurs les opérateurs ne figure pas
soyez des opérateurs et non pas répondre
des hauts critères au nab et cetera est
fixé par l'état à la reverse se trouve
dans la liste des opérateurs des gens
qui n'en sont pas les les comptes et
amis ils ne sont pas ne sont pas d'une
grande d'une grande stabilité
bref les opérateurs sont tues le doivent
être une préoccupation prioritaire ce
qui était finalement une façon
théoriquement pour l'état d'être plus
efficace risquerait de se traduire comme
une nouvelle le compte de dérive alors
dans le cas particulier c'est pourquoi
je vous parlais de d'échappatoire de la
spp venait ses fesses de la cdp nous
avons à établir vous le savez est doux
joncs d'ici à quelques semaines a publié
un premier rapport sur les aides de
toutes natures de l'état au système
bancaire et ce rapport est en cours
d'élaboration et c'est au moment sa
publication que nous serons en mesure de
dire si le choix qui a été fait de
recourir à des opérateurs plutôt que de
posséder directement était le mans peut
objectivement se poser la question dès
lors qu'il s'agit d'une garantie
d'emprunt par exemple ce que ce qu'une
collectivité locale par son conseil et
est capable de faire pourquoi l'état ne
serait-il pas capable de le faire sans
mettre en place une structure dédiée de
cet amour elle cela étant les gars
probablement il ya sûrement des raisons
et nous répondrons 1
à la question est la question posée
alors dernier point
le le problème de la des participations
de la france et en particulier si j'ai
bien compris le problème de la
participation pourrait oui celui là les
pratiques actuelles en matière de
comptabilisation de nos participations
dans les organisations internationales
les plus prompts plus généralement la
confusion qui préside à la
comptabilisation de nos relations
financières de toutes natures avec les
organisations internationales conduites
à une absence de lisibilité complète
l'exemple du fmi est particulièrement
particulièrement significatif la
quote-part de la france au fmi s'élève à
environ 12 milliards d'euros
or le solde du compte d'opérations de
l'éther qui retrace les recettes des
dépenses affecte chaque année le coût
d'acquisition de la participation de
france sous effet mis ce qui est
contraire fait dire qu'on confond la
participation et les apports à fonds
perdus d'afrique cotisations la
participation bref il est absolument
nécessaire de clarifier les choses et je
dois dire que l'administration déclarent
partager nos constats notre souhait et
s'est engagé à faire un travail de fond
dès cette année pour répondre d'ici la
fin du prochain exercice
c'est très encourageant c'est sûr que
suivre les règles et femi c'était pas
évident au travers des comptes de l'état
tout peut-être si on a encore deux
minutes
et puisqu'il n'ya pas d'autres questions
l'état est devenu l'assureur systémique
des banques établissements financiers
or n'est pas encore à la prime
d'assurance systémique mais on a créé la
société de financement de l'économie
française qui est en quelque sorte une
extension de la banque centrale pour des
du papier qui est à maturité au delà de
six mois au delà d'un an jusqu'à 5 ans
et on a confié la présidence à un ancien
gouverneur alors naturellement cette
société de financement de l'économie
française peut être amené à prendre des
collatéraux d'une qualité approximative
et donc à un moment où l'on risque de
voir apparaître des défauts et donc
l'obligation de constater des pertes
mais puisque la société de financement
de l'économie française n'est que
l'extension de la banque de france
est-ce que vous avez l'occasion d'aller
voir ce qui se passe donc de france et
de vous faire une opinion sur la qualité
du papier qui est pris en pension
on voit bien avec la crise ça se voit
particulièrement les de sa tunique
le budget de la réserve fédérale et le
budget de l'état fédéral
pour être consolidée pratiquement alors
je dis pas qu'on en est là mais
néanmoins s'il devait y avoir un
sinistre dans la qualité du papier que
pendant pension la banque de france
ceci aura un impact direct sur les
comptes de l'état
donc je voulais savoir que jean et
diligence que vous faites auprès de
auprès de la banque de france pour pour
vous faire une opinion à ce sujet et
celle que vous allez conduire auprès de
la société de financement de l'économie
française et je ne parle pas de la
société de prise de participation de
l'état
je vous remercie de 2,7 de cette
question de son président parce que nous
aurons les observations nous est
formulée à l'esprit au moment de nos
débats sur le rapport banques mais alors
pour répondre à la partie de la question
laquelle je peux répondre il nous avons
accès à la banque de france d'ailleurs
c'était plus simple à à à bâtir que
l'accès que l'accès dans les banques
dans les banques bénéficiaires de 2,2
l'attention bienveillante de l'état
parce que il a fallu que nous nous
fondions sur les conventions
les conventions passées entre l'état et
les banques pour pouvoir avoir donc ne
une barge de légitimité pour notre
contrôle ce qui n'est pas le cas avec
avec la norme de france alors cela étant
dit ce que je peux leur dire c'est que
si le collatéral est défaillant la
banque de france et d'autre en tout état
de cause nous apporterons je voulais sur
une grande partie des réponses la
question dans le rapport sur les banques
alors qui sera évidemment un rapport
d'étape parce que ça fait guère que des
deux mois que nous avons la possibilité
travailler mais compte tenu de la
sensibilité du sujet
nous pensons avant la fête nationale
avoir procédé à une première publication
et faire des stress tests en quelque
sorte
voilà
et le nous en aurons communication le
par la presse que je crois qu'il s'agit
pas dans nos rangs communication oui il
sera rendu public vous souvenez
probablement ça n'aurait pas forcément
été le cas aussi
le président de la république lors de
son intervention du mois de février
n'avait n'avait souhaité que les enfin
de lille avait dit je souhaite que la
cour des comptes vérifiés et c'est en
fait nous l'aurions c'est en tout état
de cause mais il a surtout souhaité que
ce soit rendue publique
donc nous nous poserons même pas la
question de savoir si ça doit être du
public considère cdu mi-juillet tout ça
c'est super ce sera un peuvent tout cas
ce que sera notre belle occasion de vous
accueillir
je m'en réjouis par avance ce gouteyron
ce matin vous interrogez j'ai un peu de
scrupules à cette heure ci monsieur le
premier président à poser ma question
d'autant plus qu'elle est d'autant plus
de scrupules qu'elle est très sectoriel
je veux dire d'abord que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié nos appréciations si nous
permettait de dire sur la l'application
de la naulte et et je pense que ces
appréciations mériterait un
développement important en particulier
quand vous dites qu il serait essentiel
que les responsables de programmes
soient renforcés dans leur rôle par
rapport aux ordis aux ordonnateurs et là
il faut une volonté politique car il
faudrait t'il définir comment cette
volonté politique peut s'exprimer mais
si vous theron passe beaucoup de temps
dans les ambassades
justement à ce propos parler des
contributions internationales
obligatoire en dire quelques mots sur le
premier président pour dire d'abord que
dans les quelques déplacements que j'ai
pu faire les quelques observations que
j'ai pu faire jusqu'à présent je
reprenne autres je ne me suis réjouie de
trouver la cour des comptes
et que c'est en effet pour eux le
parlementaire qui procède à quelques
investigations
comment dirais-je un atout extrêmement
extrêmement important je voudrais de
interrogé monsieur le premier président
sur les la part respective des
contributions obligatoires et des
contributions volontaires
on voit effectivement la part des
contributions volontaires augmentait
pour tous les pays d'ailleurs et moins
pour la france que pour d'autres pays
mais j'aimerais savoir quelle
conséquence ou quelle conclusion on peut
t'en tirer qu'est ce qui est souhaitable
qu est-ce qu il n'est pas moi j'observe
que les contributions obligatoires
la visibilité française n'est pas très
grand les plus dans les contributions
volontaires or la france les augmentent
moins que les autres et nous avons sur
ses contributions volontaires un pouvoir
de contrôle plus facile que sur les
contributions obligatoires
j'aimerais avoir votre appréciation
monsieur le président nous avons analysé
l'emblème ne peut que pose de président
du théron et d'abord probablement le
problème majeur de l'ensemble du système
multilatéral
c'est que du double c'est d'abord de la
volonté de certains des pays les plus
riches et d'aider les états unis en
particulier de ne plus voir
l'utilisation de l'argent décidé par des
majorités incertaine et caetera et
parfois même hostile
il y a eu blocage des cotisations du
niveau des cotisations obligatoires
et donc des besoins qui désormais sont
en quelque sorte assumée par accords
bilatéraux entre la direction générale
de la de l'institution concernée et
d'autre part le pays et le pays pouvant
de ce fait choisir quelles sont les
opérations qui seront financés et
d'autre part se glorifier de ces
opérations alors que se glorifier d'une
cotisation est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus difficile ça c'est là le premier
la première raison de cette de cette
évolution la deuxième la deuxième raison
c'est un bon le fait qu'il ya de tels
besoins des organisations
internationales que celles ci sont prêts
à mettre en place tous les systèmes
possibles et imaginables pour réussir à
faire financer de la dépense permanente
part de la contribution volontaire
occasionnel
enfin bon c'est il s'agit de deux serres
de l' équilibre en permanence alors sein
est le seul effet positif que cela parce
que ça permet aux contrôleurs
parlementaires de chaque pays d'avoir un
accès à la contribution de leur pays
qu'ils n'auraient pas normalement si non
car il s'agit alors dans le cas de la
cotisation appartient à l'organisation
qui a son commissaire aux comptes sur
l'audit interne et il est impossible
pour le l'auditeur ou l'institution
d'audit d'un pays d'aller mettre son nez
il faut dire d'ailleurs que si tout le
monde me faisait continue nombre de pays
sarron escale l encombrement bien la
compagne en l'inconvénient c'est que les
institutions internationales vont perdre
leur nature et et perdent leur caractère
démocratique c'est d'augmenter savoir la
france a suivi alors tout en rappelant
son attachement au système traditionnel
la france pour ne pas paraître moins
généreuses que les autres a suivi le le
mouvement étant précisé qu'il s'agit
généralement de la transformation de
fond de coopération en contributions
volontaires pour les mêmes pays
donc on a la france et je ne prends pas
un exemple au hasard à une action de
coopération mali pour faire joli via le
bel été où l'unesco
elle va la traduire en contributions
volontaires affecté à ceux ci sauf entre
temps l'organisation rappliquer 7 ou 10
% du total
au passage pour ses frais de gestion et
son label
voilà je prends dix cinémas n'y a pas
que maastricht
il ya également la comptabilisation de
l'aide au développement
il vous fait faire l'objet
l'investigation particulière outre les
apports effectif il y a tout le génie
dans la comptabilisation de ces
différentes opérations est à l'oeuvre
voilà qui est encourageant jésus passion
soit de nature à calmer la dépense
publique mais enfin à nous revoir merci
encore monsieur le président messieurs
mesdames vous venez de suivre l'audition
de philippe séguin par la commission des
finances du sénat pour revoir cette
audition notre site internet public
sénat point fr quant à moi je vous donne
rendez vous cet après midi 16h30 pour
l'examen du projet de loi sur la fusion
entre la caisse d'epargne et la banque
populaire
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt